use the real zeros of the polynomial
function y is equal to x to the third
plus three x squared plus x plus three
to determine which of the following
could be its graph
so there's a
several ways of trying to approach it
one we could just look at where what the
zeros of these graphs are what they
appear to be and then see if this
function is actually zero when x is
equal to that so for example in graph a
and first of all as always i encourage
you to pause this video and try it
before i about to i before i go out
before i show you how to solve it
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so let's look at this first graph here
it's zero it clearly has a zero right at
this point and just by trying to inspect
this graph it looks like this is at x is
equal to
negative three if i were to estimate so
that looks like the point negative three
zero so let's see if if we substitute x
equals negative three here whether we
get y equaling zero
so let's see y let's see negative three
to the third power plus three times
negative three squared plus
negative three plus three what does this
give us
this gives us negative 27
this gives us positive 27.
this gives of course negative 3 this is
plus 3. these two cancel out these two
cancel out this does indeed equal zero
so this was actually pretty
straightforward graph a
does indeed work you could try graph b
right here and you would have to verify
that we have a 0 at
negative this looks like negative 2
another one this looks like at one
another one that looks at three and
it'll and if and since we already know
that a is the answer none of these if
you if we input x equals negative two x
equals one or x equals three into this
function definition right over here you
should not get 0 and you'll see that
this doesn't work same thing for this
one if you tried 4 or 7 for your x's you
should not get 0 over here because we
see that the real function does not
equal 0 at 4 or 7. another giveaway that
this is not going to be the function
is that you're going to have a total
you're going to have a total of three
roots let me write this down
so you're going to have a total of three
roots
three roots now those three roots could
be real or complex roots
so
and the the big key is complex roots
come in pairs
complex roots
in pairs
so you might have a situation with
situation with three real roots and this
is an example with three real roots
although we know this actually isn't the
function right over here or if you have
one complex root you're going to have
another complex root so if you have if
you have any complex roots the next
possibility is one real
and two complex roots
two complex roots and this right over
here has two real roots that's not a
possibility that would somehow imply
that you have only one complex you only
have one complex root which is not going
to be a it's not going to that that is
not a possibility now another way that
you could have thought about this and
this would have been the longer way but
let's say you didn't have the graphs
here for you and someone asked you to
just find the roots well you could have
attempted to factor this and this one
actually is factorable
y is equal to x to the third plus 3x
squared plus x plus three as mentioned
in previous videos factoring things of
degree higher than two there is
something of an art to it but oftentimes
if someone expects you to you might be
able to group things in interesting ways
especially when you see that several
terms have some common factors so for
example these first two terms right over
here
these first two terms right over here
have the common factor x squared so if
you were to factor that out you get x
squared
times x plus three which is neat because
that looks a lot like the second two
terms we could write that as plus one
times x plus three
and then you can factor the x plus three
out we could factor the x plus three out
and we would get x plus three
times x squared
times x squared plus one
x squared plus one
and now
your zeros are going to happen or this
whole y remember this is equal to y
y is going to be equal if y is going to
equal zero if either one of these
factors is equal to zero so when does x
plus three equal zero
well subtract 3 from both sides that
happens when x is equal to
negative 3.
when does x squared equal 0
when does x square or when does x
squared plus 1 equals 0 i should say
well when x squared is equal to
negative one well there's no real x's no
real valued x's there's no real number
x's such that x squared is equal to
negative one x is going to be
x is going to be an imaginary or i guess
i'll just say more general terms it's
going to be complex valued so once again
you see this you're going to have a pair
of complex roots and you have one
you have one real root at x is equal to
negative three